Y
P.R. RELATED.
THEY'RE VERY CRITICAL OF THE
JUDGE DOING THAT, AND THE DOJ
SAYS THEY WILL RESPOND.
>> JOHN, WHEN YOU READ THIS, IS
THIS A SUBSTANTIVE LEGAL
DOCUMENT, OR IS IT -- I MEAN AS
MAGGIE AND KAITLAN ARE SAYING, A
LOT OF PUBLIC RELATIONS?
>> I THINK IT'S A LOT OF PUBLIC
RELATIONS.
IN FACT, IT IS SO WEAK THAT THE
LAW THEY RELY ON -- FIRST, THEY
DON'T EVEN CITE IT PROPERLY IN
THEIR BRIEF.
BUT IT'S U.S. VERSUS NIXON, THEY
CLAIM GIVES A PRESUMPTIVE
PRIVILEGE TO ALL PRESIDENTIAL
DOCUMENTS.
WELL, THAT'S NONSENSE.
IF THEY'D READ THE CASE, THAT'S
CITING A COURT OF APPEALS
AGREEMENT, AND THEN THE COURT --
THE SUPREME COURT IMMEDIATELY
MARCHES AWAY FROM THAT AND SAYS
THERE IS NO SUCH PRIVILEGE
PRESUMPTION.
IN FACT, IT IS SUBJECT TO THE
RULE OF LAW, WHICH EMBRACES
GRAND JURY INFORMATION OF THIS
NATURE.
SO IT IS A P.R. DOCUMENT.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
>> JUDGE, HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A
FILING LIKE THIS?
I MEAN IS IT -- YOU KNOW, AS
THESE FILINGS GO, HOW DOES IT
RELATE TO OTHERS YOU'VE SEEN?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO
BEGIN.
HAVE I EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS?
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS A SEARCH
WARRANT AFFIDAVIT IN WHICH AN
FBI AGENT HAS SWORN TO FACTS ON
WHICH THE PROBABLE CAUSE -- ON
WHICH THE SEARCH WAS BASED.
THERE ARE PAGES AND PAGES IN
THIS DOCUMENT IN WHICH THEY'RE
JUST SAYING STUFF, NOT SWORN TO.
THEY'RE JUST MAKING STATEMENTS,
YOU KNOW, THAT ON THEIR FACE,
SOMEONE NEEDS TO SWEAR TO.
AND I IMAGINE THERE WAS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT SWEARING TO ANY OF
THIS.
AND, YOU KNOW, AS JOHN DEAN WAS
SAYING, THERE'S NO PRESUMPTION
OF PRIVILEGE HERE.
IT'S REALLY JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE IN THOSE
BOXES, FIRST OF ALL, PRESUMABLY
MATCH THE SCOPE OF THE WARRANT,
WHICH WAS THEN BASED ON PROBABLE
CAUSE, AND ARE COVERED BY THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT OR
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
SO, I MEAN, I THINK THIS IS A
P.R. MOVE AND NOTHING MORE.
>> MAGGIE, DO YOU HAVE A SENSE
OF WHAT THE TEAM -- I MEAN, WHO
IS AROUND THE FORMER PRESIDENT?
WHO IS INVOLVED IN THESE SORTS
OF -- I MEAN, HOW DO THINGS GET
DECIDED IN TRUMP WORLD RIGHT
NOW?
WHO ARE HIS ATTORNEYS?
WHAT'S THE PROCESS?
>> LOOK, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
DONALD TRUMP IS ALWAYS FIRST AND
FOREMOST HIS OWN ADVISER ON
EVERYTHING, AND THAT INCLUDES
LEGAL ISSUES.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY NOT A LAWYER, SO
PEOPLE CAN DO WITH THAT WHAT
THEY WILL.
HE LIKES TO FIND LAWYERS WHO
WILL DO WHAT HE WANTS.
BUT HE HAS BEEN THE PERSON, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, WHO WAS SLOW ON
WANTING TO DO ANYTHING.
HE HAS A HANDFUL OF LAWYERS
AROUND HIM IN VARIOUS CASES,
ANDERSON.
REMEMBER, THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
LEGAL FRONT HE IS FIGHTING ON.
ONE IS EVAN CORCORAN WHO WAS
PRESENT ON JUNE 3rd, WHEN
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
CAME FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND RETRIEVED ADDITIONAL
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL THAT WAS
STILL THERE.
HE HAS A LAWYER NAMED JIM
TRUSTY.
HE HAS A FEW OTHERS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT
OF LAWYERS WHO HAVE TOLD HIM OR
TOLD HIS TEAM THEY DON'T WANT TO
REPRESENT HIM.
HE IS NOTORIOUS FOR NOT PAYING
HIS BILLS.
HE IS NOTORIOUS FOR NOT
FOLLOWING ADVICE.
SO IT DIDN'T MATTER SO MUCH,
ANDERSON.
A, HE HAD A DIFFERENT GROUP OF
LAWYERS WHEN HE WAS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, NUMBER ONE.
BUT NUMBER TWO, WHEN HE HAD THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY BEHIND
HIM AND ESSENTIALLY THE STATE,
FOR LACK OF A BETTER WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT, WAS INVESTIGATING
HIM, HE STILL WAS THE STATE.
AND SO IT WAS JUST A DIFFERENT
POSITION.
HE IS NOT IN THAT POSITION RIGHT
NOW, AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS IS LEADING.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THERE WILL BE
CHARGES.
WE KNOW AT THE MOMENT IT APPEARS
TO BE ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS.
BUT HE IS IN A VERY DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN WE'VE SEEN HIM IN,
I THINK, EVER.
>> JOHN DEAN, I MEAN, WE'VE SEEN
DEFENDERS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT KIND OF PUT OUT EVERY
KIND OF REASON FOR WHY HE WOULD
HAVE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
SITTING IN A STORAGE UNIT AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
I JUST WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING
THAT KASH PATEL, THE FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE ACTING
DEFENSE SECRETARY CHRISTOPHER
MILLER IN THE WANING DAYS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAID.
>> IN OCTOBER OF 2020, PRESIDENT
TRUMP PUT OUT FOR THE WORLD TO
SEE A SWEEPING DECLASSIFICATION
ORDER, AND HE DID IT VIA SOCIAL
MEDIA.
AND THEN IN DECEMBER AND JANUARY
ON THE WAY OUT, I WITNESSED HIM
DECLASSIFY WHOLE SETS OF
DOCUMENTS.
SO IT IS NOT INCUMBENT UPON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS LAWYERS
AND HIM AS A TARGET OF THIS
INVESTIGATION TO SHOW THAT HE,
IN FACT, DECLASSIFY THEM.
IT'S UP TO THE GOVERNMENT, WHO
HAS THE BURTDEN OF PROOF, WHO
ARE TRYING TO DEPRIVE A MAN OF
HIS LIBERTY, TO SHOW THAT NO
SUCH ORDER WAS IN FACT GIVEN.
>> JOHN, DOES ANY OF THAT MAKE
SENSE TO YOU?
DO YOU SEE ANY KIND OF COHERENT
LEGAL STRATEGY IN ALL OF THIS?
>> IT'S A PUBLIC RELATIONS
STRATEGY AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A LEGAL STRATEGY.
HE REALLY -- IT'S QUESTIONABLE
IF HE DID ANYTHING THAT WOULD
HAVE DECLASSIFIED THE DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE RELEVANT HERE.
>> THERE WOULD BE A PAPER TRIAL.
>> THERE WOULD BE A PAPER TRAIL,
AND THE DOCUMENTS WOULD HAVE
BEEN MARKED AS DECLASSIFIED, AND
THE REST OF THE WORLD WOULD HAVE
BEEN TOLD THEY WERE DECLASSIFIED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ISOLATED
DOCUMENTS.
THERE ARE TYPICALLY MULTIPLE
COPIES.
THEY'RE LOGGED.
THAT'S HOW THEY KNEW THEY WERE
MISSING BECAUSE THESE DOCUMENTS
ARE LOGGED EVERYWHERE, AND THEIR
WHEREABOUTS IS KNOWN.
>> YEAH.
>> SO I THINK WHAT MR. PATEL IS
DOING IS GETTING HIMSELF A
FRONT-ROW SEAT AT THE GRAND
JURY, WHERE HE'LL BE TESTIFYING
VERY SOON UNDER OATH, AND WE'LL
HEAR WHAT HIS STORY IS LATER.
>> I JUST WANT TO BRING ONE MORE
PERSON INTO THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OUR PANEL BOXES ARE NOT
BIG ENOUGH.
CNN'S CHIEF POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER OBAMA
SENIOR ADVISER DAVID AXELROD.
WHAT DOES THE FORMER PRESIDENT
POTENTIALLY GAIN OR LOSE BY
REQUESTING A SPECIAL MASTER AND
PROLONGING THE PROCESS?
>> WELL, AS HAS BEEN SAID BY
OTHERS SQUEEZED INTO THESE
BOXES, I DO THINK IT IS A LOT
ABOUT POLITICS AND PUBLIC
RELATIONS.
I THINK THAT IT IMPLIES THAT
THERE IS SOMETHING UNTOWARD
ABOUT THE MATERIALS THAT WERE
TAKEN, THAT THEY MAY BE BEING
USED IN WAYS THAT ARE
INAPPROPRIATE, YOU KNOW.
I DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
"SPYING," BUT THAT'S WHAT
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS THINK, YOU
KNOW, THAT THE FBI WENT IN AND
SEIZED THE PRESIDENT'S
DOCUMENTS.
AS THE JUDGE POINTED OUT, THESE
AREN'T HIS DOCUMENTS.
THESE DOCUMENTS BELONG TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I REMEMBER HOW RIGOROUS THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS PROCESS WAS
WHEN I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND, YOU KNOW, SO THE WHOLE
THING IS ABSURD.
BY THE WAY, PATEL IN THAT SAME
INTERVIEW WAS ASKED, YOU KNOW,
ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
DECLASSIFYING.
HE SAYS, WELL, THE PRESIDENT
JUST SAYS IT, AND THEN THEY'RE
DECLASSIFIED.
AND THEY SAY, SAYS IT TO WHO?
AND HE SAID, WELL, YOU KNOW, A
WITNESS.
I MEAN, THE WHOLE THING WAS
ABSURD.
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT -- I THINK
THE ADVANTAGE IS POLITICAL IN
HIS MIND, ANDERSON.
>> DAVID, THERE'S ALSO THIS NEW
NBC POLL WHERE IT ASKS, DO YOU
CONSIDER YOURSELF TO BE MORE OF
A SUPPORTER OF DONALD TRUMP OR
MORE A SUPPORTER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S NUMBERS
HAVE GONE UP SINCE MAY WHEREAS
GENERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS GONE DOWN.
DO YOU THINK THESE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE HELPING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, THEY MAY BE HELPING HIM
WITHIN HIS BASE WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I THINK IT'S RILED THEM UP.
IT'S NOT HELPING HIM OVERALL.
HIS NUMBERS ARE NOT IMPROVING
OVERALL, AND 57% OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THAT POLL SAID THEY
THINK THESE INVESTIGATIONS
SHOULD CONTINUE.
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE BEGGING HIM NOT
TO ANNOUNCE HIS CANDIDACY FOR
PRESIDENT UNTIL AFTER NOVEMBER
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT WILL HURT
THEIR CANDIDATES TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING.
HE IS AN ALBATROSS AROUND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY NOW, EVEN AS
HE'S STRONG WITHIN T